o srpc com a poesia é bom né
e vocês também serem recebidos por essa
turma que está aqui há sintoma de jovens
nem fazendo este evento
bom dia pra todos vocês então eu sou
leonora e vi um pouco contato a minha
história do que a gente está construindo
a quem vitória nem espírito santo é
enfim tem uma coisa na vida que sempre
me incomodou muito desde criança que a
desigualdade seja ela social seja ela
econômica nem seja um pouco dessa
desigualdade finalmente acabou de
mostrar pra gente isso sempre me
incomodou profundamente e eu vim venho
de uma família de classe média baixa que
sempre morou muito perto de uma favela e
essa favela se chamava buraco quente e
eu sempre ficava me perguntando por que
que existiam aquelas pessoas ali e
quando eu olhava pro outro lado existir
pessoas que tinham tanto
outro dia eu recebi uma dessas mensagens
que a gente recebe pelo hat zap e aí a
pessoa disse olha seus reduzisse o mundo
numa aldeia e nessa aldeia tivesse 100
pessoas né mais ou menos seis pessoas
iriam deter mais de 50 por cento da
riqueza que circula na face da terra
e eu sempre me perguntava como gente
como assim é como que a maioria das
pessoas no mundo não têm oportunidades
não têm escolhas e outras têm tanques
nem foi aí eu com meus 13 anos de idade
acabei começando a participar das
comunidades eclesiais de base subiu o
morro pela primeira vez na minha vida em
um dia que me emociona muito até hoje né
porque subir um morro do buraco quente o
encontro deitado no esgoto que passava
em frente um morro onde normalmente a
gente tinha que pular pra passar tinha
tido um assassinato e lá estava um homem
morto e era naquele momento e aí me
perguntaram qual seria o nome da minha
palestra eu disse olha pra mim é um
divisor de águas o primeiro momento de
divisor de águas na minha vida né
popular daquele homem eu tive uma
certeza única que eu nunca mais
ia deixar de fazer isso na minha vida e
realmente nunca mais deixei acabei ano
para a tecnologia nem especializei em
psicologia social
encontrei meu marido que estava atrás no
último banco é engenheiro mecânico
somos extremamente apaixonados um pelo
outro já estamos há mais de 30 anos
juntos mas psicólogo casa com o
engenheiro e saiba no trecho e tem um
trecho assim eu saía com ele e em todos
os lugares que eu ia admitir encontrava
o morro acreditam isso é uma coisa que
trabalho eu descobri que eu nunca mais
ia deixar de ter na minha vida né porque
onde eu ia eu encontrava o morro e aí já
só me deixava hoje porque o meu trecho
já parou aqui jamais 12 anos nega de
quase 15 anos hoje e aí vim para victor
em pretória em 2001 e quando chegou ao
território que o encontro o morro de são
benedito né
enquanto morro são benedito com oito
comunidades vizinhas ali e aí descobri
então que era algo super interessante na
vida de se fazer que era de novo subir o
morro que eu já fazia já há muito tempo
todo 54 anos então por aí vamos ver
quanto tempo eu tenho de caminhada nessa
área social
bem aí fui eu promovo de são benedito
chegando lá encontra uma organização não
governamental chamada série que
trabalhava com 300 crianças e
adolescentes comecei a trabalhar de uma
forma voluntária de repente apareceu a
oportunidade de uma parceria e assim a
gente vai tocando mais parcerias é uma
parceria com o instituto c&a e há idéias
que a gente ia trabalhar com
adolescentes que na época tínhamos
procurado ea gente fazer com elas um
projeto de customização de roupas bem
esse projeto foi tocando
de repente os adolescentes existiram
dinheiro de modo a chegar recursos vocês
sabem como são demorou adolescente já
existiu quem nos procura as mães das
adolescentes dia teste me parece 60
mulheres
meu deus os seus 60 mulheres em 2002 a
gente não tinha bolsa família a gente
não tinha uma possibilidade diferente mo
a maioria morava naquelas casas de
madeira que como diz ela se ocupe fosse
embora
casa ia cair nem era mais ou menos assim
né
e assim as duas mulheres então resolver
um problema minha filha não quer não mas
eu quero
quando eu li porque não foi nem jesus
toma conta que vai ser da gente trabalha
com moda com essas mulheres e aí sim a
maioria analfabeta a maioria não
conhecia corsa imagem não quer isso
já viram uma mulher que não sabe o que é
amarelo o que não é vermelho e no dia
então que a gente juntou duas cores e de
uma terceira
uma delas quase que ainda que a vi foi
no meu deus do céu
minha vida é preto e branco que agora
ela pode ser colorida
quando assim gente e aí a gente começar
a falar que gerar trabalho e renda para
essas pessoas é simples não é
como é que a gente ia trabalhar com moda
nesse sentido
precisava que a gente sair pelo morro
pegando uma folhinha aqui uma folhinha
daquilo lar passando uma folha de papel
falou isso aqui é vermelho né a maioria
das mulheres que com problemas de
violência e tudo mais vinha aquele
maravilhoso de lá em cima do morro
sequer nunca tinha pisado uma tralha um
dia uma delas venceu pela praia do canto
quando o marido marido resolveu deixar
e aí a gente fez uma excursão eo marido
foi junto e aí quando ela passou uma
vitrine não manda toda cor de rosa maria
fala baixo mulher fala para essas coisas
a gente não fala em voz alta não olha
essa vitrine que você não pode olhar e
aí então a gente foi trabalhando assim
com as mulheres em todo aquele movimento
até que essas mulheres descobriram que
elas podiam ter uma feira nós vamos
convidar convidados para ir a uma feira
bom pra ir pra feira precisa de dinheiro
né e aí então a nossa lar como é que nós
é uma armadilha vai para o banco
fg trash e aí nós somos sabe aquelas
mulheres blusinha assim é assim daquele
chinelinho que não vai avaiana
obviamente juntar 15 e nós vencemos
aquele morro atrás de empréstimo nos
bancos que tinham no pé do morro todos
os bancos tradicionais que você imagina
imagina o que aconteceu
a resposta de todos os gerentes foi nã
para vocês a gente nem presta no fim nós
somos a igreja
mandelson da igreja ficava só falto
jesus cristo sai da cruzes
daí ele saiu apareceu uma alma boa que
está vivo até hoje não impressos e 300
reais e assim começou a nossa vida no
outro divisor de águas foi embora pela
feira vendendo tudo o que a gente tinha
voltado para casa com 800 pegamos e
pagamos empréstimo de 300 com 500 reais
chegam todo mundo andando com aquele
empréstimo natal de 2002 e agora o que
fazer até que uma fã do simpere gente de
novo os bancos a gente pega 300 desses
500 depositá la com 200 a gente começa
tudo de novo e aí nós fomos quando
chegamos ao gerente sabe os mesmos 50
questão de em todos
todos eles disseram assim o dinheiro de
vocês vocês podem pôr na poupança elas
falaram você vai perguntar se a gente
tem aquele negócio que modo chamado cpf
web vai perguntar se a gente tem
endereço lá não vou perguntar e aí a
gente começou a questionar a questão da
economia
foi aí que nossa história efetivamente
começa e essas mulheres começaram a
fazer uma diferença profunda naquele
morro porque elas começaram a emprestar
dinheiro para aquelas pessoas endereço
nós não tínhamos até aqui há um tempo
atrás a prefeitura nos reconheceu
começou a vender e sua gente com muita
luta muita luta a gente conseguiu fazer
isso e hoje o morro todo tem o endereço
e se chama território do bem
nome dado por a nossa pela nossa
população aqui moram por volta de 35 mil
pessoas em oito comunidades de baixa
renda neste território eu vou estar
sendo rápido as fotos quem é da kia
jaburu são benedito está na areia
consolação bonfim engenharia e bairro da
penha floresta é este o território é ser
a casa onde as mulheres efetivamente
morava a gente ainda tem muitas hoje e
agora a gente está querendo assim como a
mente também em breve vocês vão ver um
site nós ea gente quer é que as pessoas
colaborem que a gente possa pelo menos
construir uma casa dessa por mês
não assim mas o tijolo ecológico que eu
vou mostrar pra vocês
esse vai atender hoje a gente tem um
núcleo de desenvolvimento comunitário
núcleo de finanças solitária sobre
sociedades um núcleo de habitação
o núcleo de divisão das nossas
tecnologias e cada um desses números
vai criando projetos diferenciados que
eu vou mostrando aqui pra vocês
esse é o nosso grande projeto e é onde a
gente começou a somar não só na gestão
realmente falou mas nessa coisa
geométrica passada porque o que nos
interessa é que venha um fórum chamado
fórum bem maior
não há muitas pessoas mas sim uma pessoa
que na próxima reunião ela possa levar
mais uma e que na próxima cada uma das
duas possam levar mais uma e assim a
gente vai nessa progressão geométrica ea
gente criou hoje um fórum que é o fórum
de governança local
olha gente e quando as pessoas da
comunidade se reúnem eles conseguem
pensar em todos os seus problemas e
trazendo solução para esses problemas
esse é o banco bem a gente tem uma moeda
social essa moeda hoje está saindo do
papel está se tornando bem é dinheiro
nós estamos começando agora uma moeda
social eletrônica essa é a situação dos
comércios que a gente já emprestou esse
são clientes do banco hoje a gente já
emprestou já circulou nessa comunidade
um milhão setecentos mil reais
emprestados para mais duas mil famílias
nessa comunidade
hoje nós temos uma central de compras do
bem que reúne os comerciantes temos uma
fábrica de tijolos ecológicos onde a
gente está construindo as casas para as
pessoas
junto com crédito habitacional nós temos
os arquitetos que fazem toda a
programação das casas temos um programa
ecológico chamado apps do bem que
transforma ponto surge lixo em lugares
gostosos a gente ficar como o parque do
bem temos uma nascente hoje a gente já
fez a rota das nascentes
temos as oficinas escolas que acontecem
hoje a gente faz todo o trabalho de
capacitação e geração de renda na área
da culinária na área da moda na área da
marcenaria temos uma variável agência de
comunicação a gente forma jovens e
adultos em toda essa área de produção
jornalística o texto jornalístico temos
o calango notícia que um jornal
comunitário feito por essa comunidade e
aí junto a gente tem outros projetos
culturais chamado nós amamos lage
lendo em qualquer lugar e eu termino
então com vocês como uma história
dizendo o antropólogo fez uma
brincadeira com crianças de uma tribo
africana ele colocou um cesto cheio de
fruta junto a uma árvore disse para as
crianças que o primeiro que chegasse
junto às árvores ganhar ia todas as
frutas dar do sinal todas as crianças
saíram ao mesmo tempo e de mãos dadas
então sentaram-se juntas para aproveitar
a recompensa quando antropólogos
perguntam para elas porque elas a viagem
dessa forma elas disseram poder ele
perguntou nem sabendo que entre um deles
outros poderiam ter os frutos só para si
eles responderão o luto
o ubuntu como é que um de nós pode ser
feliz se todos os outros tivessem
tristes
o ubuntu na cultura chuvosa significa eu
sou porque nós somos é assim que é a
nossa comunidade do território do bem né
cada um é porque existe uma comunidade
com uma governança local que cada um é
trair os meus contatos né pouco tempo
para a gente poder falar da história da
vida da gente de 54 anos mas não da
minha vida e da vida de uma comunidade
de 35 mil pessoas que têm transformado
essa história né e assim eu agradeço a
cada um de vocês pela atenção
muito obrigada pelo carinho obrigado ao
pessoal do ted pelo convite e eu espero
que a gente possa então conversar e nos
momentos dos intervalos
obrigado
a jogada do tento